okay people the school board is making
us discuss the dangers of drugs with you
two cops are here to talk about it
listen don't listen I don't give a
so your little kids like drugs oh you
think a little puff puff snort snort
school huh sound like fun yeah yeah I'm
high right now well we'll see how you
feel about drugs after this slide show
the is a slide show this is Timothy
handsome innocent smart only half Jew he
was on his way to Harvard Business
School on a full scholarship until he
met Jamarcus
Jamarcus introduced Timothy to marijuana
now Timothy is a fat blimp loser who
can't see his feet and smells like
Funyuns legend this is Chang Chu Lu
honorable disciplined and we're assuming
excellent math until he met Jamarcus Tim
to Marcus out here slinging like the boy
Marlo it only took one snore the nose
candy before Chang believes he could fly
he could oh snap last and least meet
Darryl Darryl was an honor student and
star vus football team who surprisingly
had no illegitimate children or police
record until he met Jamarcus gave Darryl
Molly it's a popular party drug known to
help kids lose their inhibitions yeah
get it dear
Darryl caught aids oh not the Magic
Johnson kind the full-blown Matthew
McConaughey in Dallas buyers club car
nickel what so kids if somebody offers
you drugs just say no man don't nobody
have to offer us drugs
where'd he got them shits you don't got
them shits anymore we raided your
lockers this morning as of right now
Chamberlain Heights is drier than your
teachers clam
- in me
[Music]